joining us now author of Wow what a book
this was from the very beginning it is
the Russia hoax the illicit scheme to
clear Hillary Clinton frame Donald Trump
great Jarrett and investigative reporter
Fox News contributor Sarah Carter let's
start with you the legal aspects of this
is as clear what has happened it's
really a small group of people it is but
what they did is a spectacular betrayal
of the trust the power the tools of
intelligence we gave them and headline
today is that William bar is personally
reviewing the conduct of the FBI in
launching the Trump Russia collusion
hoax you know he knows and there's a
plethora of evidence that the process by
the FBI was corrupted by political bias
and personal animus just look at the
text messages from Peter struck their
virulent ly anti Trump their profane and
he's leading the investigation of Trump
there was never any credible evidence to
launch the investigation and Lisa page
verified that in her own testimony Comey
grudgingly admitted it and then they
made matters worse they lie to Pfizer
judges to obtain a wiretap warrant so
all of this I think William bar is going
to investigate and when he receives
sometime this week from members of
Congress a criminal referral he will
read what they are laying out the facts
the evidence and the law which will
initiate I believe a criminal
investigation by bar all that James
Baker revealed here that Hillary's
behavior was alarming it was appalling
and worse and he was arguing to indict
her the top lawyer in the FBI he didn't
have the power or authority to over
overturn call me in this this band of
Clinton supporters here this is what's
so interesting Sean because the most
important point here is that Comey went
out before the public and said no
reasonable
prosecutor would bring charges against
Hillary Clinton
yet his general counsel had been
fighting with them for I don't even know
how long in fact throughout the whole
investigation basically arguing that
this was gross negligence up until the
very last day and that's in that's in
Baker's testimony when he finally
changed his mind and he didn't answer as
to why it was as if he said he was
talked into it at the very last minute
he decided to change his mind but you
could see that he was appalled by it he
was disgusted by it and then the fact
that Comey came out and made that
statement just shows that Comey was
being dishonest from the very beginning
Attorney General William bar has a lot
on his hands because he doesn't just
have to look at the cross fire hurricane
investigation when it started at the end
of July but he is really going to be
looking at what happened before that
with Stephane Halper the mole that was
working for the FBI who was in London
and his contacts with George papadopolis
and how that all unfolded and also all
the information that leaked out on
general Flynn this is vitally important
to understanding what was going on there
and and I am Telling You Lieutenant
General Flynn is the big mystery right
here right answers are gonna come
forward what what we know McCabe and
Comey did bragging about setting him up
and knowing the FBI didn't think he lied
and that's what he got charges because
they're probably threatening his kid
with potential investigation of jail all
right so the rest of the meeting tonight
they're focused on okay the Muller
report and well maybe he did obstruct
justice but let's go over what's coming
we have Tom fitting in the next all of
the FOIA requests are coming out Sarah
criminal referrals this week by newness
bar pledging today an investigation the
IG report on FISA abuse leaking report
by Hoover release of more closed-door
testimony thanks to Doug Collins of
Georgia
the FISA applications gang of eight
materials 302s now of course the Ukraine
incident okay that's
coming this there's no way this house of
cards can stand at this point from my
perspective it has no foundation Shawn
it is collapsing around everyone and I'm
going to tell you one of the big things
that we can't forget here is how the
senior officials within the Obama
administration played into this let's
not forget about John Brennan let's not
forget about James clapper and certainly
not James Comey we need to look into all
of this and we need to find out what
really happened because what happened
here was senior officials we're trying
to coup a sitting president let's go the
Department of Justice was giving the
marching orders to the FBI to clear
Hillary Clinton they created a legal
standard that doesn't exist in the
statute and that was the excuse to clear
her and on the very same day that come
he cleared her that's when the Trump
Russia collusion hoax began I got all
applaud both either you're a big part of
all this in this ensemble team that did
the work that nobody else in the media
would do thank you thank you